what is your ideal man he has the brains
of george clooney
in the body of joe biden interesting
dave and i are going on our first date
tomorrow
i'm not nervous why should i be nervous
we're just two people going on a first
date
there's nothing to be nervous about
that was my phone ta-dah
that looks great yeah will you be
wearing it out of the store
today madame oh i think i will good lady
hey while i have you can i ask you a
question shoot what if he asked me if
i've been married have you
no well then say that but then he'll
wonder why i haven't been married
you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna say
that i was married the real question is
should i say that i have kids
guys like girls that have kids right
whoa what if i get drunk and i talk
about darfur too much
or not enough what if i don't bring up
darfur enough leslie relax
yeah okay i just have a few more
questions for you ann
what if he shows up with another woman
what if one of my sleeves catches on
fire
and it spreads rapidly what if instead
of tic tacs i accidentally pop a couple
of ambien and i have to keep punching my
leg to stay awake
those are all insane hypotheticals and i
promise you they won't happen
they have happened all of these have
happened to me
uh no there's more uh one time i
accidentally drank an entire bottle of
vinegar
i thought it was terrible wine once i
went out with a guy who wore
3d glasses the entire evening oh one
time i rode in the side car on a guy's
motorcycle
and the side card attached and went down
to flight of stairs another time
i went to a really boring movie with a
guy and while i was asleep he tried to
pull out one of my teeth
i literally woke up with his hand in my
mouth we went out a couple times after
that but then he got weird
you know isn't it funny how these setups
are always just so awkward
hey watch this i will now extinguish
this candle with my bare hand okay
go that really hurts are you okay
oh god it looks so much easier on the
internet god i gotta borrow some
ice
hey dave it's me it's leslie hi leslie
it's great to see you you
don't want to do that quite yet huh so
dave
let's begin our conversation
what's on the note cards they're
possible topics of conversation
whales parades electricity
and the rest are blank yeah i couldn't
think of anything else
leslie's in worse shape than i thought
she practiced laughing oh
dame you
so you never told me where you're from
i'm from pawnee keep still please
what kind of music do you like can i
answer that sure keep still
all kinds very important that you keep
still at this moment leslie
i've told you that a thousand times
do you ever break your arm you can
answer that here i'll turn it off
one time i was on my bike and some boys
were making fun of me so i
chased them and i lost control i'm
surprised you can see that
it was like three years ago i can't
believe i turned the machine off for
that
you never had any kids right leslie no
you've got a great oven okay time to go
got
ample room in there honestly if you
wanted to
you could go triplets right off the bat
leslie you got a big
industrial sized oven so we're done
right hi dave
you're late and i can see your nipples
through your dress
what no really in nursing school we took
a psych course on how to treat phobias
with a method called exposure therapy
so like if you were afraid of snakes
they would immerse you in a tank of
snakes
so i am going to immerse leslie in a
tank of
bad date you're 20 minutes late i almost
left
okay well i was uh dropping my niece off
what's your niece's name torpel what i
don't know
that's not a name i don't have a niece
my niece's name is stephanie stop lying
hey look there's bread you want some
oh no oh i got flowers in your soup i'm
so sorry um
just i have to go to the um
whiz palace you know dave the the place
where you
you know the toilet thing
it's a bathroom it's called a bathroom
why would you say that dave that dog was
like my best friend and when she died
bring brain brain bring bring hey
tiffany
yeah i definitely want to see you
tonight
no i can't really talk right now cause
i'm on a date with this drip
yeah i can ask hey do you want to watch
a porno after this with me and my wife
no dave cause you're disgusting
so definitely no i don't understand why
you're being so terrible
we're just two people trying to go on a
date it's supposed to be fun it's just a
date
you're right it is well done
sorry i had to get all medical on you
but now you see that even if everything
goes wrong you'll survive
well well well you
coy bastard
i can't even believe that i was scared
to go on a date with you
i mean you should be scared of me okay
i think i need to return the sweater i
get
fused with my shirt in the dryer or
something yeah you think that's a
sweater shirt combo
i think it's going pretty well with dave
he wants me
i can totally tell that he wants me i'm
right here you know i'm here right
you know i was only with mark for one
night and then i was hung up on him for
six years
i dated dave for three months so if i
continue that
pattern i won't be over him for
500 years you ready to rock this profile
all right yellow-haired female
likes waffles and news sexy well-read
blonde
loves the sweeter things in life much
better hobbies
organizing my agenda wait that doesn't
sound fun um
jamming on my planner favorite place
upstairs there's this mural of
wildflowers and i like to sit on a bench
in front of it
really it could be anywhere in the world
paris hawaii
the grand canyon nope just the bench in
front of the mural what about like an
actual meadow where wildflowers
ew and i'm scared of bees mural okay
what do you think of dogs
love cats love fish love
turtles no opinion
they're condescending describe your
ideal man
he's dark and mysterious and
he can sing and he plays the organ
i think you just described the phantom
of the opera hmm
okay oh my god a 98
match it's a soulmate level match i i've
never seen anything this high before
awesome okay i know what you're thinking
and
you know what you have to forget about
ben he had his chance and he blew it
this computer could have found the
future mr leslie knope
yeah okay entire universe of guys i
might date let's see what you got
let's play a different game i'm gonna
say stuff about me and you say on a
scale from one to ten how interested in
that thing you are
ready okay i love sunshine and fresh air
and early morning walks
one i've read five biographies of
eleanor roosevelt one i work at the
parks and recreation
that's what you do one i once kissed a
girl in college
eight where i graduated summa [ __ ] laude
in history one zero
negative a billion don't talk about any
more please the only thing that's
important to you is hotness
wendy lucy all you cared about was the
shape of their boobs no
i really like them and they happen to
have nice breasts you're acting really
weird
would you even buy me lunch for just so
you could yell at me for what i like
about women
okay i promise not to tell anyone sure
this is insane but you and i got matched
up
on hoosiermate.com 98
match soul mate level match
you want to date me this is a date this
is not a date
okay uh you took me to a fancy
restaurant you paid for my meal
and you're trying to get to know me
better i was just trying to figure out
why only sleazy guys are into me right
now
nice try you love me
leslie knope tom haverford dating in the
day
dating in the night dating all day cause
he's keeping it tight
all right tom dating in the car dating
on the floor
beating everywhere cause she wants some
more
what yeah are we gonna yeah
hey what is wrong with you leslie it's
the workplace you're being a little bit
too feisty right now you are being a
little bit too much of an ass
right now okay knock it off i can't
fight this feeling anymore
you and i we're dating
you should be so lucky leslie huh
tom
fishing fix that
you